entropy in boltzmann formulation is just
look
when you look at a system a macroscopic
thing
a glass of water with an ice cube in it
or cream and coffee or an egg
you don't see every little bit of that
system you don't see the molecules you
don't see the atoms of which it is made
so let's take cream and coffee as a
classic example okay
if the cream and coffee are separate
from each other
there's a number of ways you could
imagine changing the positions of the
individual
molecules in the cream or molecules in
the coffee
so that macroscopically you wouldn't be
able to tell the difference
but if you started mixing them together
if you started taking the cream and
mixing into the coffee you would be able
to tell the difference so there's a
small number of rearrangements you could
imagine
whereas if it's all mixed up right if
all the cream and all the coffee are
mixed together
then there are a large number of ways
you can rearrange the atoms and
molecules
to make it look exactly the same so
boltzmann says
that's what entropy is entropy is a way
of
counting how many ways there are to
rearrange the fundamental constituents
of a system
so that it macroscopically looks the
same to
us from that point of view it's not at
all surprising that entropy
goes up as a function of time it's
simply because there are
more ways to be high entropy than to be
low entropy
if you have a medium entropy system and
just let it go
let it do its thing let it evolve into
the universe
it will naturally increase in entropy
since there are so many more
configurations that look that way
that part is easy the hard part is
if you have a medium entropy system why
was it lower entropy in the past
if it started lower entropy you can
explain why but you seem to need a new
principle to explain that
and indeed that is exactly true think of
the arrow of time
this way there's no arrow of space right
if you were an astronaut floating out
there in space there'd be no difference
between up down left right forward
backward
but you know if you're here on earth
there's an arrow of space you can tell
the difference between up and down
nobody thinks that arrow of space is
deeply ingrained in the fundamental
nature of reality
it's just because you're in the vicinity
of an influential object
the earth the same story is true for the
arrow of time the arrow of time
according to modern physics
is not built into the fundamental nature
of reality
we experience it because we live in the
aftermath
of an influential event the big bang
14 billion years ago for reasons that
cosmologists
do not understand the big bang was
very low entropy the early universe was
very orderly compared to what it could
have been now
why is that true good question very
active research question at the
frontiers of modern cosmology but for
our purposes today
we don't know why but it's true the big
bang had a low entropy and once you say
that it's clear that entropy is going to
go up it's been going up for the last 14
billion years it's going to continue to
go up
billions and billions of years into the
future